yet I've noticed I have uncanny
attraction to people whose Heritage is
from where I'm from
I was from that area until recently
Ukraine Ukraine and Ukraine
yeah yeah but but I like my wife I was
like you know and it was like why why
it's like it's like it feels like it's
in my DNA do you mean women
[Music]
and clear skin yeah
he's like I don't know what's wrong with
me where's my magnifying glass so you
need that yeah because I like that too
yeah so well no no that you're getting
there
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby we're starting let's do it
uh doctor take it off welcome welcome oh
glad to see you guys again I know man
wait a minute since probably covered
maybe last time I saw you was when we
did uh we did King this thing was it
it's been different incarnations I I you
mean Theo did something yeah
a pillow talk yes uh for 90 days because
we're so okay
a sign of how horrible the coveted
lockdowns were that we were watching 90
Day Fiance the trashiest forward to
everyone what I mean him we're about to
do it after like show yeah
and then we looked at our schedules and
it was just like oh do we really do you
are the last guy I would ever think
would watch that show but you know it
it's too hot to handle I watched another
one because my wife watches oh you know
it's what my wife's like loves just goes
down no no I don't know how you guys
missed this one but it drives drove me
insane MILF manner
I knew it right away I thought oh
they're going to bring their sons in
here yes I knew exactly it's I'm not so
it's older women with younger men if but
all of those women roles all those
women's sons are the younger man yes
well that's weird yes it's weird it's
very edible
it's very awkward oh God that's well
because the younger the other young
dudes are hitting on the mall and and
you you know it's an interesting example
of how social how uh reality shows work
you could tell they were in sort of a
Stockholm syndrome because they they'd
bring somebody in from the outside and
they like kind of break out of it like
what's going to do it what am I doing
it's so interesting that one's a weird
vibe yeah that one and then I got really
into uh um Love is Blind oh yeah we did
the first season and then you find out
love is not blind it never works out
yeah
my favorite is when they do that when
they do the reveal like they connect
they've never seen each other and like
today is my day I'll meet my soul mate
and it opens like oh oh yeah dude this
can be great it just never works when I
worked in the back office of a bank I
had a total love affair with a woman on
the phone oh yeah I have to talk to her
every day and she was so amazing she was
just like her voice I know everything
and I was like I'm gonna marry her and I
said we have to have lunch
you know what I look like I walk and I
see her go
and she was
oh I'm sorry not my type no she was that
she was she had not been missing a lot
of meals it was just a whole but I think
that show like the experiment is Love is
Blind it's actually not it's like it
should be friends are blind because you
guys connected and you guys are gonna be
great friends you have a lot of Simmons
similar uh you know things in common and
having sex as far as just a sexual
attraction it it's very visual for both
parts both that's what I want to know if
both of them are having the same
experience because men are very visual
but women are too you know that's what
that's my takeaway from I watch every
season I love that show but you'll see
the women are usually the ones like he's
just not my type yeah like there's this
one she's the most attractive girl on
the show she is paired up with a
shoulder like shorter kind of very nice
like kind of bait a male type dude and
he was like am I your time she's like I
wouldn't technically say that she's like
usually I date what six six full sleeve
tattoos she's talking about former
professional athletes this guy's exact
opposite of course it didn't work out
yes it just didn't work that's right
there well that's interesting too
because that's kind of We Are physical
so they say women know right away they
can see a man they know immediately if
they would have sex with them or not but
a man can talk her out of it real quick
so yes she can see a guy he's attractive
now if he's if he's got the goods if
he's cool and he knows how to behave but
she can also see a guy who's very
attractive and if he's a douchebag yeah
she might have sex with him but
typically she's going to be like there's
something about him yes he's just he
sucks men are just like you got track
marks you're a Nazi uh
talk about it after I come you know if I
could deal with him I'll navigate
through this exactly it's not bad race
she's a Nazi but she's got curves yeah
yeah that show was absolutely insane
well biology is funny they did this
study on um because uh this woman Naomi
wolf wrote a book called The Beauty myth
which is the idea so Naomi's a good
friend of mine is she yeah I don't she's
eating [__] lately because she dared to
question the vaccine narratives she did
she's she's a brilliant woman I'm sure
oh my gosh what's her background
journalist but she just she's really her
thing is Women's Health Women's issues
she really has been thinking about women
writing about women protecting Naomi
wolf wolf yeah and uh she's just so so
smart and she gets crap because she's
not a scientist and she's not a
clinician but Moy she is a clear thinker
is she but that doesn't that narrative
doesn't work so like you heard who's a
journalist is looking out for Women's
Health yeah but do you guys realize Bill
Gates not a scientist either exactly but
they go with him like well look at him
he's pushing the vaccines like he's not
a scientist well Naomi wolf and then she
could she she's she's
um she wrote this idea that that beauty
with with the small waist the big tits
all that stuff is a myth but there I
think she was taking a task on it
because if even congenitally Blind Men
yeah who've never seen before in their
life you're like this yeah yeah I mean
if they yeah if they if if they touch a
mannequin they prefer the 30 to 70 no
there's no myth I mean not all men are
the same way but men are very visual men
have certain there are standards their
symmetry we're symmetry we're looking
for fecundity we're looking for
fertility and good genes and stuff like
that ultimately uh and and then we have
our thing each of us has our own thing
and I I'm that's the part that more is
more interesting to me yeah me too
because that's much more variable yes
much more variable like chins attracted
like crowbars
there are people that are into all kinds
of stuff yeah he didn't do it he did a
show with a woman that's very heavy she
was a his feature or I mean I think
you're you're MC and uh she's big girl
and you tell the story where she was
like she was like um yeah I just wait
they did a meet and greet and she goes
I'll get I'm gonna get hit up I get more
men who hit me up yeah
secretly oh yeah she was empty the club
booked and then yeah she was in there
but they're really into it those guys
they're interested they're fetish and
she's you know and she was very open
about I didn't ask her clearance good
for her and she was like she was like
man business is booming
she goes with your crowd it's a real
cockfest so man business can be booming
tonight really so so the hell but here's
what I find odd about the human thing
human behavior which is that the more
genetic admixturing there is the
healthier the population yes okay so the
further afield the person is genetically
from us the better it is from a health
standpoint yeah yet I've noticed I have
uncanny attraction to people whose
Heritage is from where I'm from and I
didn't know I was from that area until
recently
Ukraine Ukraine and Ukraine
yeah yeah but but I like my wife I was
like uh you know and it was like why why
it's like it feels like it's in my DNA
and so that sort of Czech Austrian
polish Ukraine thing I'm like helpless
do you mean women
and clear skin yeah
he's like I don't know what's wrong with
me where's my magnifying glass so you
need that yeah because I like that too
yeah so well no no that you're getting
there
it's not even you're not quite in that
zone yet you're not it's so funny look
up you know who was who was in that Dawn
free was from Knightdale fiance Yara oh
yes okay
he was in that frequency yeah
let me see who is that yeah that's my
yeah that's sort of my zone hey hey
perfect true yeah hey Doc it's in
everybody
yeah that's terrible right there if
you're into girls yeah
you guys are funny no no it is weird
though because that that's your thing
but that makes sense because you you
said you shouldn't be like that it
should be the opposite I should be like
I'll go go find like somebody to try the
other side of the world well I guess
well that explains Mike because my
thing's uh Latinas like I see Latinas is
that yours yeah your genetics yeah yeah
no it's not my general oh okay yeah I
know I love your skin but I I'm not I'm
you know and by the way I'm like like if
you showed me the picture of what you're
into I'd have the same reaction of Brian
yeah
of course yeah
his wife has the kind of backside I
literally we were walking and I stopped
her I go Joe like seriously seriously
she goes what I go I mean I it's it's
out of control yeah her waist is like
that is come on and she's like
let's take a little break can we take a
break and this one is a good sponsor to
have on the show because we got Dr Drew
we got a doctor he's an MD yeah but you
pay a lot for prescription drugs unless
you have Rex MD I mean listen I like Dr
Drew but even though he's a doctor I
hate going to the doctor's office takes
forever that's why Rex MD makes getting
generic and branded viagrancy house easy
you're gonna go to the doctor sometimes
you're like hey Doc I'm having a little
problem he'd like to do my wiener won't
wake up yeah now if you know him you can
say that but for most people it's
nervous you don't you don't have to go
to a doctor no and Rex MD delivers
straight to your door no office visits
no talking to receptionist just super
simple you know if Viagra can cost 90 a
pill dude I thought it was 9 million a
pill no it's Rex MD has the generic
Viagra for just exactly the same thing
two dollars a pill this is insane all
you got to do is fill out a quick
medical questionnaire on their website a
doctor will review your situation
prescribe your generic Viagra if
appropriate it gets shipped right to
your door with free two-day shipping
it's fast simple and cheap and you can
access your us license rxmd physician
anytime you need afterwards rxmd has
helped over 300 000 Bros get generic
Viagra quickly conveniently all right
act right now take advantage of their
deal by heading to rexmd.com fighter
this is an exclusive deal you can save
up to 90 off where you'll pay as low as
two dollars per dose on generic Viagra
instead of 90 on Viagra starter packs of
generic Viagra Cialis are available
right now to the final kid listeners and
viewers that's rexmd.com Fighter for up
to 90 off plus a free gift your partner
will thank you I think you heard us
talking about how good these macadamia
nuts are doctors came here because I
want them as an appetite and because we
have you know these nuts we have
Macadamia House of macadamia that's all
over and he goes man are these healthy
try it forget healthy why don't you bite
into one oh and he goes oh why my keto
low carboh go ahead buddy dude he's he
ate half of our half of our shipment yes
he did well they are truly delicious
they're probably the best nut Health
Wise you can consume they have a and a I
guess a fat profile that is better than
pretty much any other nut it helps with
satiety meaning you feel satiated so
you're trying to lose weight and you eat
macadamia nuts you'll feel Fuller for
longer dude how some macadamas are so
hot right now you got Brett Weinstein
talking about Joe Rogan Rick rube and
Tim Ferriss the two of us farmer owned
by the way we're all known they can
guarantee the best quality and prices
all right they also have a bunch of
other stuff like nut Butters they got oh
dude I got that nut butter right there
they got nut bars they got the nut
cooking it's got a higher smoke point
olive oil you're talking about the cold
press extra virgin Macadamia yeah
buttery flavor dude it has more of the
good kinds of fat today right now we
have four bags of the white chocolate uh
dip macadamias and if you if those touch
your lips dude that chocolate I'm the
white chocolate guy but I'm also the
dark chocolate guy or whatever you don't
discriminate dude you like throwing them
discriminate bro me neither dude and
listen they never run discounts but give
me this because you guys listen to this
show how some macadamus has a very
special offer use code tfak for 20 off
your order and for a limited time we're
giving you guys a free bottle of cold
press extra virgin Macadamia Oil worth
rub it on your body and in your hair
macadamias.com that's House of
macadamus.comtfak get yourself
m-a-c-a-d-a-m-i-a-s yeah but I mean
there is a thing about so they say that
you are attracted to your mother is the
first sort of female yes so that plays a
role seems to but I I'm wondering I they
used to be a lot more made of that than
in recent years I'd say probably I I
think it's also interesting by the way
there's an interesting kind of sideline
a quick like complete sidebar here but
psychoanalysis had a grip on the
American Psychiatric system for like 50
years and it screwed everything up these
guys were at not good the edible thing
or they they essentially felt that
everything was psychological everything
and they got to the point where they
felt they got kind of in the zone we're
in these days where everything is put on
by Society and including mental illness
itself was caused by Society caused by
institutions so they dismantled all the
psychiatric hospitals and guess where
the patients went the street streets and
the prisons and by the way and nothing
has changed since and I I I have not
ever forgotten that I've quoted you many
times we did a podcast and you said you
went to Sacramento and you would bring
up the fact that homelessness was a was
not a housing problem yes it was a
mental health problem I was calling them
murderers too I told them they're all
murderers and they did they came out man
but you should double them down oh they
kicked me out for trying to they're
finally talking about this they kicked
me out for trying to talk about Gravely
disabled because they're you know you
can hold people against their will if
they're going to kill themselves or kill
somebody else if five minutes later they
say I'm just kidding even if they have a
gun access you can't do anything it's
ridiculous but there used to be forever
something called Gravely disabled which
is what you're seeing all over the
streets these people are great they are
gravely disabled and they're finally
starting to bring that back are the
Democratic senator Brian it up I was
like oh my God thank you I I see these
people and I'm like this person needs to
be in a hospital of course then we don't
have enough hospital beds we don't have
enough psychiatrists they need to build
more build yes
it wouldn't cost more than what they're
doing that's what I'm saying amount of
money we have the homeless industrial
complex now oh my God you you have ngos
financed by billionaires where the CEOs
are making a million dollars a year yeah
and there are there's billions of
dollars circulating to help homeless
billions and billions of people think
it's a money problem it is not a money
problem no you're not going to get rid
of that uh you're not going to get rid
of that cottage industry well it's also
there's a legal problem as I said you
know you can't you can't give people
custodial care you can't hold them
against their will when they're really
sick the only country in the world that
does this the other countries do it they
care sick people they're sick so are we
is it coming back when a patient went to
Japan they held her for four months
against her will because she was wild
and on drugs and things and they've come
out of it better way better
it's called Gravely disabled yes and
that was a Supreme Court decision I
think the state couldn't hold well
really it's California has been leading
the way the whole was because the land
from Petra short act lanterman himself
went to his grave believing he'd done
something horrible yeah yeah it has been
it's been it's never good when
California is leading the way that's
usually right bad sign
a good buddy of ours I was on his show
recent me and him are just trash in
California I went dude why don't we just
leave he's like I know I'd love I'd love
to find him I think he's gonna I think
he's going I would like to too but I'm
so in I've been here forever I'm so
entrenched sunshine my daughter's in
high school I'm not taking her anywhere
yeah we do kids are in high school
that's also an entrenchment you can't
change their life when they're younger
it's not as big high school hey ditch
all your friends and we're going nowhere
you know what's really interesting to me
is I spent a lot of time in New York
City and I have property in New York
City and I pay taxes in New York City
and same as it's a very similar tax
structure to California I feel delighted
to pay the taxes because you get so much
transportation and city services and
parks and they take care of their
homeless they they do things in New York
we just don't do anything here there's
nothing no water no roads no electricity
but the basic government functions no I
worry also that California now that
they've waged war on all these business
people like Elon Musk and Valley that
they're not going to have that tax win
full oh they're they're going to be in
big trouble big problems man they don't
have a tax base yeah it's not going to
get better here that's what like mean
girls are talking about he goes listen
he goes these are my two requirements
for me to leave they have to have a Top
Golf on a PF Changs I was like well dude
Adam High culture I was like man
serious and then a caller goes this is
my pitch to Brendan Adam to move to
I think it was Cincinnati and he's like
giving this whole pitch and I'm gonna
stop stop look it up you have a top golf
PF Chang the guy goes yeah we do he goes
send me a picture of you in front of it
I'll move there
with a newspaper yeah yeah that's what
he said he goes because any economy that
has a top golf and uh PF Chang's means
they got their [__] together he's like
I'll move them like man your standards
are pretty low
it's us it's California I know you're in
you're in Pasadena yeah yeah forever
yeah literally I like Pasadena it's a
great town by the way Pasadena I have no
quarrels about passing a city services
power yeah they waited on power it's all
trash police they've been acting and the
reality is we should be much more
interested in our local government than
anything else what is the federal
federal government since when do we get
so preoccupied with the federal correct
agreement correct they were always like
interstate commerce and and protection
and defense politics is local
everybody from John Adams to
um with the French guy that wrote
Democracy in America the talk field they
all said the same thing that was what
made it work that we focused and
participated locally that's right
although L.A County
I think I got a couple of notes
when you got the Board of Supervisors in
San Francisco and L.A and they're not
even Democrats they're socialists that's
going to be I don't know if that's true
in in LA but certainly in Chicago
they're
socialists oh God they're not Democrats
but they're they're literally Chicago
man no I'm talking about I'm talking
about San Francisco they voted in that
reparations bill so everybody who's
black on The Descent of slaves five
million dollars knows eight mil way to
go with that uh but Drew you're you're
talking how do you discussed you you'd
even run for
it's so funny you bring that up now I I
in the middle of covet I was so
distressed I'm like I'm gonna do
something I gotta do something this I I
can't live with like this and uh and
then I realized I lived in Adam schiff's
uh District I'm like well that I that
guy's doing nothing for me yeah he's on
nothing for our district found out he's
very um tied in with the Armenian
Community because he advocated for The
Armenian Genocide which okay I'll do
that I'm happy to do that too
um but he he does nothing for for his
district he's busy doing whatever he's
doing out there in Washington but
um I just this week got a letter from a
physician for a woman who wrote me a
letter to say and with a 25 check
begging me to run for his office when it
comes up you should and uh what would
you consider it I called her because I
was so I was kind of moved I'm like it's
up here you know I thought I should talk
to her and she went to her neighbor's
house who apparently very wealthy women
in a political mover and I believe
they're begging me to run I thought and
I've Got a Friend brand that's an Army
Ranger and every time I see him he's
like gets under my skin like your
country needs you now when your country
calls you must respond your country fire
me up now do you see a guy like Dr Oz
that run obviously completely different
than you see Dr Oz is kind of he's a
good friend yeah and I called him
afterwards and he was just like oh my
you can't imagine what it's like that's
what I was going to say like I'm from
the outside like we know politics is
dirty but I'm sure Dr Oz now is like oh
yeah they had a political strategist on
who who's you know Old Times helped
everybody and he he looks at candidates
who come to him like this like her new
and he goes says um
as long as you're willing to go through
a car wash ten thousand times that's
what it's going to feel like well and
and my wife's not up for it either I
know much more kids are the last time I
put well I needed some high prostate
cancer I needed some radiation that was
that became my excuse like I got
radiation this summer yeah aren't you
busy enough like you want to add that on
yeah I would shift to that it would have
happened yeah be a full-time I think
you'd be I think because in hindsight Dr
Oz is probably like never doing that I I
probably true I've always been
fascinated with the federal government
just his history and stuff and yeah I
just I just like the whole deal everyone
I've ever spoken to that goes into
Congress just goes yeah you can't
imagine horrible it is I come in with
all these great ideas it's like loving
sausages then you work out the fact
you're like this is disgusting
his office in the capital and talk to
him about the just how government really
works yeah it's like none of us really
ugly nobody knows yeah well so read a
book by called the fifth Risk by uh uh
Michael Lewis who wrote yes big short
and he wrote large book great book great
book and what he did what it is he shows
you actually all the services government
does do that we don't know about so I
always talk about this on stage but you
know the reason you don't worry about
geese flying into the engine of your
plane is the Department of Agriculture
has ornithologist scientists that are
there that shoot fireworks off and they
know exactly when to shoot fireworks off
to keep keys out of the Airfield not
only that they throw Frozen Birds into
the jet engines before they approve them
yeah to make sure to make sure they can
continue operating after a Frozen all
kinds of stuff they keep peregrine
falcons to keep all the other birds out
of the area no that's great but they
can't fix the pothole off my street well
I know this is what he says he says
government so Michael Lewis looked at
like so stem cell therapy okay uh and uh
immunotherapy which is saving a lot of
lives all started actually in with in in
Government research funding oh you know
government's funding too much yeah
what's interesting about all that is
that we benefit from it but it's such a
complicated organism yes it's got I
think it's got five million people in it
the federal government something crazy
and there's one guy he found he found
one guy in uh in Washington who is
responsible for a lot of the
organization of the different
departments and he understands literally
everything about government but it's
such a complicated organism it's there's
so many things going on yeah and and
this is the other thing you get a bill
as a congressman you get it and it's uh
it you get it a day and a half to two
days before you're gonna vote on it and
it's 1200 Pages yeah yeah you're not
going to vote that's why you got a team
though right do your team doesn't have
time your interns are reading it I'm
telling you but I think a lot of people
the Senators are a congressman never
read this no they read pieces that gets
thrown in front of us but but I think I
think like a lot of people I even think
uh Obama had like one make a change but
then you get compromised somewhere down
the road yeah we're like oh I actually
don't have as much Spanish as I thought
it was all the way back in yeah there's
no way you you you're yeah just convince
me to forget it
someone brought it up I'll go back to
watch United fiance
all the life I got two books when you're
when after we do this and then also
they're gonna put you through the car
wash and you do that uh was it after
hours pod which kind of a run like yeah
yeah my wife and I my wife's on that too
and she talks about stuff stuff like
anal and stuff like that oh well that's
a problem it's all gonna well yeah of
course in debates the guys I'm like you
want to vote for this guy yeah he does
blocks yeah
they're gonna call you anal Doc and yeah
you'll have some Anal bastard
the thing is though if I were to do
something like this I'd have to get all
that [__] together over all these years
of how many good luck get ahead of it
and have you guys push it out
like this is who he is this is what he
does we told herself Walker we'd offer
that business he turned it down look how
that happened no that's that's so funny
man how virtual Walker was like I'm just
gonna run so I was like do you but what
about the kids stuff
if you really want to know what politics
if you a congressman what it's like all
you have to do is I've done this you go
to Washington and just go to the street
I can't remember the street but you're
not allowed to you're not allowed to
call and raise money for your campaign
on government grounds so what you'll see
is you'll see a rows of cars you could
probably look this up okay Congressman
in the car
with a list of donors and they have to
call their donors and they're on the
phone so really at Lawrence right at
Lawrence uh what the [__] is his name a
camera's name Lawrence uh something he
wrote a book called Republic lost and he
did a thing Congressman spent between 40
and 60 of their day yeah and their time
raising money I know yeah yeah that's
new yeah Republic laws politics yeah
Lawrence lessick I'm an amazing guy
bring up Dr Drew's uh what's it called
after hour after after dark after dark
it's like you guys should be on it why
don't you come visit me it's 100 we do
it in Austin uh we got our boy Josh on
I'll be out in Austin I'll be in Austin
uh in August let me try to tell me
exactly when I'll try to schedule the
show okay
because our boy Mike catherwood lives in
Austin I know when I was out there he
just doesn't live in Austin he's on like
a farm did you go visit him no I didn't
have time I know it's an hour outside
yeah
yeah the best but he's he's in Austin
he's just crashing it he comes in and
does this once in a while as Rudy yeah
yeah the whole Rudy thing and uh so we
have lots of good the Christina wanted
who's Lauren
I was just gonna say that but then I was
like you know what she does well she's
on that particular episode she taught
yeah I talked about Disney jail her
first time having sex was on Pirates of
the Caribbean
right
it's the story is unbelievable I mean
it's episode 212. and she uh says they
they finished the whole they were the
only people on the ride for some reason
I forget what she the reason was and
they they get to the end of the ride and
there's like a team of guys there with
mops and like like they do this all the
time and they they grab her and the
boyfriend put them in handcuffs and take
them to Disney jail damn what how long
did they contain her for did they use
cuffs she's comedian she's a comedian so
you guys are interesting comedian I
think she's gonna have a Regular Show on
uh on your mom's house she's
unbelievable yeah she's cool
she's of course that's Brian's zone I'm
talking about these zones
yeah she's a beautiful woman she looks a
little bit like Laura sanco right that's
everybody's zone am I wrong my Lord
yeah alrighty there's nobody pirates of
the two nobody goes like this yeah
nobody goes can you can you call up the
video just to see what I guess it's too
much it's too crazy to do all that is
there any like copyright stuff on this
or is there what he owns it though I
know I mean we still have to yeah I mean
you're my permission but I own it with
Tom Segura so yeah cause you're on uh
your mom's house that's what this is
yeah yeah and then then my wife would
kill me by the way if I did this week on
Doctor all right just go forward
you could go keep going keep going there
I think I keep going keep going I think
oh boy we're just looking at videos it's
I think we look at horrible videos there
oh I think that was it I think the
virginity stories sublingual Disney
sublingual yes
[Music]
she can hold her on she's good yeah no
no I mean that makes it even worse
that's uh that's so she's also smart and
funny it's a big problem but on that on
that show you cover everything
everything you've had Jason
had a rough showing there he was he's
been down lately he's been feeling you
guys must talk to him he's yeah he's
better he's better but is he doing
better now I talked to him a few months
ago oh he got worse
oh poor guy poor yeah yeah my breath
away I love Jason yeah yeah you just
feel for him yeah he's a great guy man
yeah Beyond I've been an adjacent fan I
was probably an early adopter yeah uh
because he's just a great guy and he's a
real person and got a lot of [__] going
on he's not the actual about talking
about it yeah I love him because he's
always been waiting same reason I love
Doug Stanhope these are you just they
just have their stuff and they're like
good I I don't get pejorative about
people's stuff people stuff is people's
stuff I have stuff you have stuff and if
they want help with it then I then I
want to help and I can and I worry about
them because I know where these things
go yeah if they don't deal with them but
that's just as because as a friend I
worry about why do you think uh why do
you think that is is it to what ratio is
it trauma what ratio is it for what uh
uh whether whether it's depression
addiction whatever it's it's all uh I I
just speak in general sweeping terms I
have found it to be true when it comes
to psychiatric illness and human
behavior both
generally not always not 100 of the time
but generally you can count on about 60
of the phenomenon on the basis of
genetics alone oh well a little more
than 50 percent generally about 60 and
cocaine makes it better genes are not
Destiny especially not with the cocaine
in there no nobody gave a bunch of
cocaine it was like I got better nobody
well you know it you know Freud thought
he found the first antidepressant yes he
did okay and then his friend got
psychotic and he thought better of it
that's right so Jeanette so 60 when
they're born so you're born with these
potential genes are not Destiny but if
you manifest a something a behavior or
an illness about when it comes to brain
and psychiatric pathology about 60 is on
the basis of genetics alone that's a big
generalization but it's generally true
for sure true in addiction and
alcoholism for sure 100 and isn't there
like there's a subset of a population
people of northern European extraction
some of those people when they drink
alcohol experience Euphoria it's not
drunk it's it's it's like probably some
similar what happens to people when
they're doing below
generally there's more of that in people
who have the alcoholic potential yeah
the the now that's never been proven
that's something I've seen repeatedly my
alcoholics you know I drink a glass of
wine I want to go to sleep my alcoholics
want to go repave the front lawn repave
their driveway they get that same thing
with opiates I am down with an opiate
they feel up they want to go to work I'm
gonna do stuff that's often the way it
starts at least and uh the other thing
with the genetic potential for
alcoholism the only marker that actually
has been proven to be associated with
the potential of alcoholism is
resistance to alcohol intoxication
if you're somebody that can drink your
friends under the table and Grandpa was
an alcoholic you gotta watch out wow
it's also genetic students that play a
part in obesity as well because
everything like
um
this Dad came up to me in the sun you
know same age as my son uh he was on the
other soccer team he's like man we're
trying his kid's bit the big like lizzo
big not in a good way he's like we're
trying to figure out I'm like well
what's his diet like is it prone to it
already I'm also not a doctor so you're
talking to me you're already [__] but
it's like the kid it's like the kid is
eating seven Snickers at night but again
he's like but don't your kid eat like
that I'm like yeah but look at his mom
look at me like we're not prone to
obesity right exactly so it's the two
genetics and environment yeah and now we
have ozembic and Manjaro and all this
cool stuff but but every that's why I
recommend I said he's seven get him on
his epic yeah but but people
also don't listen to me we didn't have
an obesity problem in the 20s and the
30s and the 40s and the 50s did we well
not like this and and I was I was
reading a Twitter thread from a woman
that I follow and she was saying she's
from I forget what country and she said
she came here eight same diet and gained
weight on it and I thought isn't that
interesting we have so much more corn
Stars we have as much stuff in our food
we know it's yummy we you know it's all
terribly designed to make us eat and buy
more and the portions are big huge
portions are huge compared to everywhere
else in the world yeah I remember I was
in Holland years ago and I was trying to
buy a Denver omelette and I and I'm like
no one omelette and they're like ham and
cheese in the same um
it's true you're in France and they'll
have they'll take lunch and it'll be a
salad with some tuna yeah they're like
damn and they're just like but I don't
know four hours later you go back to
work yeah yeah but I don't know how you
break that cycle because if you look at
like the food it's like if you're trying
to eat healthy like the cheaper faster
options fast food
I've loaded up on chocolate macadamia
now you feel good it helps with satiety
that that's my wrapper right there yep
it's delicious no I told you that uh the
old um
with the name I told you a few minutes
ago the old protein diet the original
Doctor Atkins diet macadamia nuts were
his number one recommendation for
appetite management our Boy George or
this should be 450 pounds good for you
congratulations Flex on him Doug I was
watching Brendan I was just a fan and
when he started bringing Mike catherwood
on oh yeah I was watching and Brendan
was going through a hard time the show
was in you know going through stuff and
I was you put him right out of that hard
time so I [__] to mozambers we all have
we all have we all go through our [__]
right most epic is tricky because you
lose a lot of your body mass right like
they don't know yet they don't exactly
they don't really know you're the
Twitter guy you're a Twitter guy what
news
I don't know yeah they really don't know
I have prescribed was that big by the
way I've done it and I recommended it
the other day to someone who didn't
really want it it was diabetic and so
it's it's in the Lexicon of what we're
using it's been around for a walk that
started for diabetes incorrect dude I'm
telling you the mom group that my son's
friend and I'm skinny almost all around
zapping I'm like it's working it's
freaking working these moms were Peter I
was bugging him the other day about uh
longevity stuff I'm like come on
Metformin I'm bringing up all these
things I've read about and he finally
looks at me goes vigorous exercise
vigorous exercise that's it that's
vigorous exercise and I go you know
you're right there's no easy yeah
there's no yeah so I'm gonna I I think
he's brilliant and he's got a new book
called uh longevity live I think check
it out live I think it's called yeah
recommended highly one of the best
sort of easily easiest to digest
discussions about lipids I've ever seen
he knows it so clearly he was able to
communicate what does he say about
lipids I got high cholesterol there it
is built from broken
science huge eye some of the podcast the
other day he goes because we're not
going to make 90 year olds into 30 year
olds because he's not since it's
starting it's been impossible yeah he
goes we want to make 90 year olds to be
able to feel like and be be um
functional like a 70 year old where
their body's not in the way as much like
a 60 you've never seen a nine-year-old
if you don't understand how it really
gets yeah it doesn't it's not pretty
well we see Biden it's a nightmare yeah
that last decade he's still in his 80s
that 90s it just goes he's out president
United States 80s when it beats you up
man
he is in the 12th round he's down eight
I know I don't understand I mean in my
profession you have limit you you know
you have you age out you they your peers
will come in Wellness mccutus will come
in and go this you're not you can't
function anymore you can't do it you're
going to hurt somebody most professional
like that I mean professional sports you
age out yeah my dermatologist that was
he was literally I think he was 89. he's
not working that's not good he's not
gonna work at a hospital for sure he
wasn't looking in my skin did you get a
discount I didn't get a discount these
guys can and gals can do certain things
at those Advanced stages it's not like
they're useless they can do stuff but no
you can call for an advice because
they've changed everything because his
pack was all he was the Italian guy from
Australia
I have cancer and is he the one that did
your Lids no no that's that's a plastic
surgery okay
you guys Lids done no that's different
that's because that's from Jason Diamond
who's like a plastic surgeon that
becomes a visual you'd start screwing
your vision yeah so my mother your
insurance will actually pay for it yes
because my mother because I was seeing
it on when I was doing the Goldbergs or
I was doing school yeah my eyes were
like that like a hound dog my mother
goes our family gets really bad do it
now and nobody will notice yeah and I
was like you don't understand if I do it
the World's Gonna know because I'm going
to talk about it on my podcast I got lit
up because his eyes were all black and
he's like do I feel it it's a great
procedure and he put I didn't realize
this
yeah you put fat under here and I go no
that never happened and my wife goes why
do you think you had a uh he took it
from my my uh stomach right here and put
it in there in your nose no under his
eye oh sorry you're a son of a [__] oh
yeah I could see that well I'm not do
complete the recovery
it's just that to me like
there you go Brian that's a good look
right there oh God oh my God that's
funny
she did you took that picture you piece
of [__] yeah Brian's in today got the
lids done what are you gonna do are you
supposed to ignore it you know what I'm
saying like if I got a nose job just
came on different face right right we're
like what's been up not my luck that's
exactly right that's how I feel about me
if I get a hair transplant the moment
winning with Brian to get her Lids done
B let's take a little break because dude
it's not Black Friday it's on its
Semi-Annual Sale well I'm serious about
my health so they have stuff for my
health not only do they have it but my
energy yes sure dude but on it usually
gives you 10 off Alpha Brain dude right
now the Semi-Annual Sale you're getting
25 off Alpha Brain wipes off kettlebells
and up to 60 off other stuff 60 off I'll
tell you right now fam don't wait too
long because the sale ends May 14th all
right wait they got they got they got
supplements Fitness Nutrition digital
digital Fitness apparel what yeah dude
that's right and the number one
nootropic on the planet we're talking
about Alpha Brown we got you covered man
we got you come back able try the Black
Label that's what and I swear by the
Black Label they got the instant Alpha
Brain they got the concentrated shot get
you on it right now go to onnit.com
f-a-t-k and you can get 25 off Alpha
Brain ten percent off get into the Zone
off all of those things it's on its
semi-annual sale going on right now no
exactly so you guys are good everything
yeah I think so hustling hustling on the
road doing stand up yeah yeah just
hustling through the whole day have you
been to Rogan's new place and uh he just
he just called me and asked me to come
and do a weekend people love it
comedians love it more than anybody have
you been I've not been it will be we go
there all the time do your mom sucks we
do it in Austin and I'm gonna go next
time we're down there yeah yeah if you
you go there and you're so happy about
the weekend no matter what like yeah I
mean you sold out like nine months I
have so much admiration for Joe Rogan
you know and I don't think he likes me I
gotta be honest guys oh I think so no I
don't think so we were sort of friends
at one time and then
um and I've been in Rose with them and I
and I just I really watched my staff
because I really admire him I really
admire him I'm a fan and
um and everything he I mean he thinks he
talks about thinks about and talks about
I'm just always interested what he's got
and by the way I was so Furious when his
physician was a question for what
remember the doctor put him on uh yeah
they called the CNN horse yeah again
horse pills gave him uh monoclonal
antibodies
but yeah but he also gave him monoclonal
antibodies yes and gave him a um NAD
infusion yes the the really outlying
treatment was the NAT infusion that was
incredible to me and I said Joe that's
amazing how'd that work was it good I
didn't that's between Joe and his doctor
nobody should have an opinion about that
is disgusting to me that people go
what's that doctor what that's between
the two of them totally it became
everybody became [__] Mrs Kravitz
everyone's looking out the curtains that
everybody else
man did Joe win that battle that is
disgusting yeah we should be disgusted
by that but let's call it out now we
look at well even now it still happens
to people but even it was that two years
ago yeah you look at now like can you
believe that I look at CNN who ran with
the story look at that but look what
happened they're screwed man they're
screwed it's a limitation well there
should be they should agree they should
be people we have to tell people to [__]
off I'm sorry I agree people that have
really been really lying and hurt other
people and doing awful things that you
need
what do you think about the lateral
cooperation between big Tech
Pharmaceuticals okay so we'll stop on
that but I just finished my story by Joe
I he I I did the forward to uh
stanhope's book and when he called me to
do it I thought I thought stand up was
pumpkin
can't you Johnny Depp do it for you kids
and uh no I want you to do it and I
loved to do it was very cool
I recommend the book and really if
you're in fear and loathing has got
nothing on standard yeah I've read and
it scared me I liked I love Doug and his
his wife girlfriend and uh it just
scared me oh my God Doug I'm glad you're
with us excessive uh but
um he was on Rogue in a rogue and why
don't you get a real doctor to write
your thing and I thought oh that's
interesting what's going on what are we
I think he got pissed I heard he got
pissed when I treated on Celebrity Rehab
I treated somebody for cannabis
addiction and that was offensive to him
or something he's a big bro and I'm not
I'm not anti-weed I am not interested in
yeah but I'm not interested in
legalizing we've got to get those people
out of jail that were in jail for it but
it's a real drug it has especially in
the concentrations we have now I have
family members that have been hurt by
Dave and addicted to it and I've treated
patients not everybody I know a lot of
people that use it right now I think Joe
and I've had this conversation with him
I think he I just I just had this
conversation with him we were talking
about marijuana and uh I said I can't
smoke it he goes no you can't go no
listen to me yeah I'm the same way I
can't smoke weed yeah it makes me a
zombie because when I said to him is I
go what was crazy is I watched you get
up there and do an hour of stand up and
you took a huge hit of weed beforehand I
couldn't watch him do an hour stand up
dude I know I couldn't let him do it
it's better yeah that's his chemistry
and I said everybody's chemistry is
different he knows that he agrees he
goes everybody has different chemistry
and some people react in a positive way
this guy alcohol and weed disaster for
me I don't do well I can drink two
glasses of wine and I'm I'm good and and
by the way I'm not going to function as
well the next day that's just me yeah
but I'm not going to judge you off that
no that's but you and I must be the same
like if I have two glasses of wine and
then have a glass of bourbon I'm
destroyed right that's right and I'm
miserable for you you want to have an
uncommon we like Ukrainian women with
curves
what's your ethnicity Irish Italian yeah
I was like I'll do my 23andMe you know
it's not like you look at me and go
and go [__] that Medium white guy that
High School athlete is exotic and I was
like yeah 51 Southern Italian you know
the rest is everything else yeah
everything West and it's in German so so
back to the Cozy relationship between
Tech pharmaceutical and government I am
very concerned about it yeah I didn't
really I was not aware of it before the
pandemic I am uh
apologist for pharmaceutical companies
my whole career because what what do I
do as a doctor right I either
use my brain to counsel people and you
know work in the sort of mental health
or I prescribe a medication that's it I
do not pick up a scalp I'm not a surgeon
I either or I guess I could prescribe
physical therapy and things like that
but I prescribe medication and I alter
people's physiology when there's a
pathophysiology and I rely on the
pharmaceutical industry to provide this
for me there's nothing wrong with that
though nothing wrong with that they Save
A Lot the problem is the problem is I
mean and believe me when you get sick
you want these I mean if there was even
a shortage it's not good for you for
patients
but but it's problematic is first and
foremost the Cozy relationship between
pharmaceutical executive structure and
the FDA there's a lot of back and forth
of the same people and competition stops
new uh companies just biases things it
just creates bias for profit
for the for a pharmaceutical profit but
the but the bias is is built into
everyone's psychology because I look I
was biased in favor of pharmaceutical
companies for a long time because I used
them and I needed them and I thought
they were being unfairly sort of judged
I've changed my mind
because I the pandemic exposed a bunch
of stuff that I've really been
concerning but my biggest concern is
this piece that's the number one piece
and then you said big Tech
I I don't even fully understand that yet
I I can't even I mean Elon Musk has
pulled the top off you can kind of look
under the lid a little bit of the
insanity that's going on there but I
think there's more what do you can you
kind of like what are the kind of drugs
that people don't realize save lives
that we could never do without it
everything I take two anti-hypertensive
drugs that I would have already had a
stroke if I were not taken every day and
I'm going to live to probably 80 or
something
um you know I mean just so many
life-saving drugs
you could argue about sounds insulin
what is a TSA about lipids and statins
what is the TSA Peter Peter oh he um
cholesterol
it's complicated right right we're net
we're now we're starting to get into the
it's it's not as clear-cut as we once
thought
um we're getting into the insulin story
now and the lp little a stuff and
there's a bigger story afoot with
carbohydrates also but we're we're doing
a good job we're making steady progress
there I'm on a Statin also because I
have horrible vascular disease in my
family terrible and my coronary calcium
score is 0.0 which is insane given my
family history no calcium nothing have
you had a heart scan let me see
do you see a trend with young people
with something new like more more as far
as prescribing different medications
like for second pharmacists you know
the antidepressants all the
psychological psychiatrics through the
roof right and when I was a kid it was
not a thing we're
[Music]
I the combination so the fundamentally
the fundamental problem is I I was
raised by a family practitioner my dad's
a family practitioner and he pounded
into my head that medicines are
dangerous dangerous dangerous and by the
way a lot of my career one part of my
career was doing medical management of
psychiatric patients in a psychiatric
hospital 85 of it was dealing with side
effects of psychiatric medication some
of them serious
um but he always patted to me how
dangerous medicines are I had never
taken an antibiotic until I was 16 or
something somewhere in that age and I
remember when he gave it to me is like
all right here we go we're like we're
crossing this big Rubicon I mean you're
gonna you know who knows what might
happen to you this is ampicillin and
Amoxicillin whatever it was it was a big
deal to him to prescribe a medication
and so that's in me that's a bias in me
and so when I see how people think in
terms of pills being solutions to
everything I'm Gravely Gravely concerned
about that so that that psychology needs
to shift medicines are only useful when
the the risk is worth the benefit or
that you know it's worth doing the
benefit is worth the risk rather and we
just we're not in that mindset and you
know all the public health stuff we just
went through with with the covet they
weren't doing any risk reward analysis
just stop this virus
and destroy the world in the process
burn it all down is that that that's the
that's the risk reward yeah but it was
so predictable that the mental health
consequences would be spectacular they
can go along with those lockdowns that's
crazy it is the craziest thing for me to
the whole world okay enough in the world
yeah well I will tell you
um I've I've you know I do a streaming
show my wife would kill me if I didn't
bring this up I do a streaming show at
um three o'clock generally Tuesday
Wednesday and Thursday Pacific time
though I'm doing one today at three
o'clock that's why I have to get out of
here what's it called uh ask Dr Drew let
me look that up there and I'm gonna
interview Ed Dowd Ed Dowd you heard
about his stuff yet no it now is a is a
financial statistical guy and he has
been reporting on vaccine side effects
and other things and
he apparently has some groundbreaking
data that's going to come out on my show
this afternoon I don't know what it is
but you know do you you look at all data
skeptically you look at everything
carefully don't don't I'm not prone to
run from one side of the ship to the
other but there's a lot going on so I've
learned about the lockdown thing so
here's the the broad Strokes on the
lockdown do you know anything about what
happened the broad Strokes are there was
this growing I noticed about 15 years
ago that it Masters in public health mph
was all of a sudden after all the
doctors names and I kept thinking why
are you guys getting mastered you can
practice medicine why do you need mph
why what is that so we trained all these
Public Health officials then they got
together internationally and started
having pandemic Readiness pandemic
response policies and really
gigantic systems were developed I call
them pandemic Inc these things that just
were going to be called into place as
soon as the pandemic occurs in other
words a giant hammer we're gonna nail it
with nail everything time well they had
just done a war game you know almost
identical what happened just a
coincidence as far as I can tell
wargaming what they were going to do now
they did not contemplate lockdowns
they'd been brought up many times but
everyone's like they'll destroy
everybody why would we do that and
what's it going to do a respiratory
virus it doesn't do anything you might
slow it but it'll go it just does
well China did a lockdown
the local government it was so clearly a
political maneuver do you remember the
the cars running down the street with
the chlorine being scored that was all
nothing that was theater and but it was
the local Soviet effectively the local
communist policy party people making
sure that they showed the upper echelon
that they were taking care of business
and there would be no problems they were
going to take care of this don't worry
Mr G we got this and they sent him a
graph after the lockdown and if if you
look up I'll just I'll tell you the
graph just went essentially up and then
flatlined that's inside and that was for
the entire country now everybody now
knows that was total BS complete BS
organization well everyone our our
scientists went over there and was like
oh my god look what they're doing in
China this is fantastic they reported
back to our people but we got to do this
they they've shown that it works then
Italy hit
this is the really interesting part of
story a guy Michael Sanger researched
this and the the low there were like
several Lombardi it was lumbar that was
that was uh locked down one of the
Lombardi politicians who was the big
lockdown Advocate wrote a book after The
lockdown it was immediately pulled from
the shelves because it was so
ignominious
in the book he said you know I really
didn't expect the lockdown to do
anything from a public health standpoint
I didn't expect it to to stop the virus
but I admire the way the Chinese do
things and we need to bring some of that
over here and this was my opportunity it
was strictly to bring a totalitarian
system to bear on Lombardy then when
Italy did that the rest of the world
just followed
was starting to kind of like try to back
it down a little bit and then the states
went Bluey the states went insane
California was insane here this is
ridiculous there should be like you know
what I'm thinking the whole time you're
talking don't say too much we're gonna
get flagged
oh for YouTube yeah well you already you
said the I word that you'll get flagged
just for that I said what you've said
you said the name of medication that
YouTube will shut you down for just
saying the name of it there's no way we
can end up we're gonna get flagged no
you can you can edit out in in uh
yeah I know we can but do that one just
to be safe okay
now he knows to do this but do that one
just to be safe yeah because that's what
we get flagged for and we and we always
put up a banner says you know CDC says
that screws you too no they actually go
with that that's really cool yeah
they're cool with that all right listen
I'm fine I'm fine to toe the party line
but I want us to be able to talk about
everything you should be silenced by the
way I'm talking to other Physicians and
things the Physicians aren't allowed to
talk about it that's where it gets dicey
like who is why are they suppressing
this you know what I'm saying it's like
just because we're having an open
conversation about it because I don't
want to surprise it I thought I lived in
a country where you're allowed to talk
yeah it's weird it's very strange did
you ever read democracy you mentioned to
talk Phil earlier is you read Democracy
in America okay so one of the things he
said was that even though we have the
greatest uh uh sort of Declaration of uh
privileges of free speech in the law in
practice we had some of the least
because the Town Square people would
shame you and suppress you so throw
that's right I will say that for the
battle of the Battle of speech has been
has been a reality and
the city and give you something both of
you probably haven't thought about and I
didn't until I heard about I remembered
it remember that we we also our speech
is being stifled Lenny Bruce in 1962.
yeah did four months in jail for Word
Crimes yeah it was a stand-up comic yeah
and in New York they arrested him they
put him in jail for months for for
violating obscenity laws yes and that
was 1962. he was speaking the wrong way
on a stage they cuffed him and put him
in jail and Governor Pataki uh um
Governor Pataki pardoned him recently my
buddy Ronnie marmo is doing a one-man
show of Lenny Bruce and he wrote this
op-ed piece that I read recently and you
forget these things we've come away well
the the Free Speech as we currently
think of it is a relatively new thing
that kind of real free speech yeah man
it really started after the first world
war apparently at that point you weren't
allowed to say anything against the
government that's right but there were
people saying the war was a bad idea but
during wartime there's there's there are
these special Provisions yeah yeah
during wartime like if you start you
know it's it's almost and that was one
of the things that they passed in World
War II you cannot show dead soldiers
bodies on TV because it yeah it affects
the morale of people but when it comes
to that's what that's what you know
makes me perk up it's like why are you
guys so why are you suppressing this
information if I'm just questioning it
yeah we get suppressed well what are you
what are you so scared of that's when
I'm like what's going on it might be
about it might be it might be uh private
companies I'm going to give them
benefited out I think private companies
like Twitter also scared they are scared
of lawsuits they're scared of
misinformation they're trying to do that
they're scared of cancellation yes it's
it's well hold on hold on hold on you're
giving too much of an easy out if they
were if they're scared of that then why
then then why would they mean then why
would they take money hold on be for
reals so if that doesn't work for me
you're giving too much of an easy out
because Twitter we know was in bed with
the White House in the left
and suppressing the right um
I'm just trying to say we know this for
a fact no but what I always try to do is
kind of go so Jack Dorsey is a
Libertarian right so I but I think what
happened was the pressure on everyone to
make sure that they they weren't being
hijacked by very very sophisticated
propagandists whether they were in some
troll Farm in Eastern Europe or in this
country right because there was a lot of
that going on on both sides and I think
when you're a public platform like
Twitter it becomes and you have so
little few people with that many people
doing it it becomes really hard to
manage one of the reasons that I'm going
to get flagged for this but one of the
reasons that law enforcement gets
involved in Twitter and stuff like that
is because there is a lot of Nefarious
activity on those platforms that they
have to investigate there just is but
then should you only silence one side
well if you're trying to do what's best
for just the nation would you only
suppress one side or would you
you should always do both but it it also
it seems to be I I see see I I keep
bringing Trump back into this because
Trump was the real lightning rod Trump
took this country and just atomized it
yeah Trump had Trump came along and
there were so many people here why that
happened so yes yes I think so it was so
weird to watch I was like when he was
coming in I used to do I did a show on
HLN every night and I brought in a bunch
of trump supporters and I was like what
what do you what do you see in this guy
like why are you doing this it was
impossible to predict yeah he was a guy
who most people understood was a
television personality great at branding
and had a history of aggrandizement and
in some ways a charlatan in that he was
just very good at pumping the
showboating yeah yeah but also he didn't
fit the narrative like most politicians
don't do anything like well at least
he's different he also maybe he'll get
it well that's what they were thinking I
think I actually think Trump had a
reasonable command in some ways of a
farm policy and of the economy and of
how politics works because he was
involved in all of these things right so
I'm always going to lean toward a
businessman who's been in the
marketplace and stuff like that but I I
think that overall he said certain
things that felt unhinged let me give
you a couple examples many things and
but he kept doing it
delivers his problem
some people liked his what they liked is
they didn't like his character they
didn't like his narcissism they didn't
like who he was as a person but they
loved that he was given Washington the
finger because Washington had failed
most people you know at the end of
Obama's the term the average Americans
they may have owned their house but they
had five hundred thousand dollars in the
bank that's it most Americans don't have
a cushion most Americans when you come
when it comes down to sending their kids
to baseball or choosing more food on the
table that's a real that that's a thing
and I think when you have someone he
come along goes hey how's how's it been
going for you guys and more importantly
does your government represent you do
you think that your vote actually
matters and all of us go not at all and
Along Comes this guy who's making fun of
Jeb Bush and all these washes so I get
that part then why the incredible
incredible reaction like you can grab
them you can grab me that started the
metoo movement you can grab him by the
[__] and they'll say nothing yes it did
um I don't know how many women came out
against him he was rewarded when he won
the presidency for that uh if you come
from a Muslim country I say I don't
change I'm putting a freeze on P all
Muslims coming into this country until
we figure out what the hell is going on
I remember going that's not American I
have a huge problem with that and and I
and a lot of people were cheering and
that it's his scariness then you seemed
like a like a classic authoritarian and
they don't know what movie he's gonna
make yeah but he also seemed fiercely
yeah I get that in a lot of ways yes yes
okay so that starts to make sense to me
like they think he's a boorish dummy who
has unlimited potential to do
Un-American style interviews
deep State he also went bad on our
institutions he went bad on our military
he made fun of John McCain who was so
I'm a conservative I'm more I'm way more
right than I am left I'm I'm I'm I'm in
the middle but I'm I'm right of Center I
suppose it's hard to tell now I thought
I thought I was a liberal and the whole
frame shift is what I mean that's what I
thought as a Libertarian right I thought
it was libertarian then I thought about
that either they moved probably Democrat
heavy Republican light you know
somewhere most of us are most of us if
you look at all tell me what what is the
issue yeah but um I I had because I had
spent time in New York and because Trump
to me is very funny I find him endlessly
entertaining yes and there was a lot
that I couldn't help but to like about
just his his General he's a walking [__]
you but you could laugh
when you say Barr said Barr said that if
you are if you back Trump's policies in
other words if you agree with this
political
um modus operandi he's the last guy to
ever have
Implement them because he has absolutely
no ability to follow a thought through
he's constantly distracted it's a horror
show he is too many people who work for
him came out and said the guy is the
loosest of all loose cannons yeah
we want to kill terrorists families yeah
here's the problem is you know you look
at next year in the elections it's like
all right we have Trump you know he has
his issues and then Biden on the it's
like these are our two options so we'll
always get that as long as we don't vote
you guys are I like some of the stuff
that RFK Jr is saying I agree he is
something throat problem is the problem
I know him I've interviewed him no he
had he had surgery on it so it's bad
he's better it's better better it's his
speech is gonna be his oration is a
problem DeSantis has a problem with
oration his voice is terrible oh yeah
and uh but but RFK is saying stuff that
I a lot of it's way over his key it's
like I don't necessarily but he's not
going to win though right I think I just
like just to run yeah who is this uh RFK
yeah rfk's mixing it I like guys that
mix it up and yeah and makes you think
about that correct that's what I like
yeah he's not gonna win but I like that
yeah but political insiders just chuckle
about this all the political people
follow us they all they look at us we're
talking they go like this they go it's
adorable and they change you know what
hold on hold on those are the same
people that chuckled when we said Trump
I'm gonna tell you why they're chuckling
because they chuckle and they go they
don't vote in the primary so it doesn't
matter so as long as you don't vote in
the primaries as long as none of us do
you have always I'm independent yeah
you can't stomach I'll register the
Democrats because you change every 10
minutes in California I know but if you
don't vote for the candidates that mean
something yeah DeSantis will never be
Trump because the the
mobilized energized fanatical wing of
the party they are the ones that decide
who the candidate is Jesus and I just
like RFK he's a good time and the info
too it's like he's just making people
aware of things that most people are not
aware of exactly
but I think we're going to get to a
point where uh presidents are
figureheads and they don't matter
they kind of I always thought they
didn't matters now no no I thought they
already didn't I remember when Clinton
got elected okay and I and I said oh man
the guy's an alcoholic I could tell
right away and and I'm like oh this is
gonna be terrible alcoholics yeah yeah I
didn't know that yeah and uh sexy sex
addict brilliant guy but one of my
favorite presidents of my lifetime and
so I learned two things a you can put it
you put as long as they're good
administrators I don't care what's going
on psychiatrically with them put them in
there uh and number two
um it doesn't really make that much
difference if I was knew that yeah it's
called checks and balances the great
genius is that no power it's not about a
bicameral legislation the greatest
Genius of the founding fathers and our
government is that patent power can
never reside in one group's hands and
yet it feels like right now
that's the part I like least about the
present moment it feels like there is a
a willful suppression of other people's
you know so again to talk Phil talked
about that too hey uh you like her a lot
pointing at Megan Kelly and Kelly's
great I'm attracted to her so Adam
Carolla declared her his uh perfect
woman me too I yeah dude you're in there
dude I said it yesterday my wife is my
perfect woman that's my that's that my
wife were not never born yeah I would uh
if your wife didn't listen to this
podcast yeah if my wife didn't listen to
this podcast but she doesn't that's my
girl is she single tell me she's not no
no no no
she's great she's not a free agent she's
so hot
knowable dude but but she is one of my
favorite people forget just women 52.
sign me up sign me up to the youngster
I'm 56. look at her she looks 34. what
are we doing
that's her man oh man I would fight you
right now with your cauliflower ears I
would take this why me I'll think of him
I don't know dude I'm just I'm I'm
jacked up right she's doing in those
pictures oh who needs coffee when you
can just stare at her face her hair is
smart with that voice with the short
hair there look at her in high school
look at that or whatever it is college
or something Nick there it's hysterical
by the way wow
I bring her up when she's uh 13. but
it's still funny yeah
better now better now yeah high school
was rough I I like my peers by the way I
like older women a lot I I you know what
I mean I like a little experience a
little wisdom by the way you like funny
about that older women she's like she's
like 13 years your Junior it's like oh I
know you know what I mean that's how I
feel I'm like my buddy was dating
somebody's 42 and I'm 56 and I was like
and he's 55 and I was like
she's she's only 16 years younger than
you
I mean when you were graduated high
school she was born
my ex-wife and make my everybody would
laugh so hard because she was 11 years
younger and I was like oh you're 40. wow
but she's no I I uh yeah I just lie I'm
64. man I'm old and all you guys she's
63 and she looks She's like she ages
backwards and she's like a flux
capacitor she can eat and drink anything
it only gets better everything gets
louder she's Ukrainian she's a check
which I think is the refined version
I think they went over the oh he's
chechnya chess right oh close
yeah I think one will be fine yeah 40
minutes yeah okay hold on a second
that's uh got some mustard colored pants
on
not me him come on tacky is that what
that is they're kind of a little dark a
little brownie mustard mustard that's a
little lighter right that's a mustard
brown pants as much as you and I were
gay
man oh no I'm good this is good no no
I'm I'm gonna show 40 minutes but about
an hour to get home okay nobody admires
uh masculine pulchritude like are you
like buns and the black guys I mean
relax but I mean I I find I want to look
like a black athlete wouldn't that be
nice yeah I uh do you like musicals yes
I'm going to Palm Springs in a couple
weeks
can I tell the story about the bathroom
here
oh sure yeah right it's it's we're all
it's me and Brandon and it's Delia it's
all comments we're in the bathroom down
the hallway we're doing bits in the
hallway here before like you know just
joking joking around and we're just in a
we're in a heightened silly move
everyone's pissed in the bathroom a man
walks in who's every bit of six five
maybe six six and he'd see he's
obviously a professional volleyball
player blonde he's everything you think
of as a viking yeah
okay Disney prince thank you thank you I
was trying to thank you Disney prince
walks in in his J crew outfit and I
instinctively because I'm gay I go well
that's the best looking guy in this
bathroom by far and he goes he goes he
goes oh thanks man he's just he's a dude
now he's standing at the urinal and he's
pissing with his impossible it was
awkward you guys are going to you guys
are going around Brendan just out of
nowhere let's [__] him
and you'd expect the guy to go like this
guy and the guy goes I just hear a
mutter oh and he dumps out and I I
looked around I go like this I don't
know what to say so I go sorry my
friend's weird and I went man that joke
that friends into rape yeah I mean it
did not go well yeah it was crazy oh
that's funny you can find the guy to
apologize to him for real well he's
probably a great pie he's a dude
yeah so we're we're waiting no he's fine
he's did you go on the board and see if
there's any volleyball these companies
so we can watch him with his shirt off
yeah
by the way
over here okay I have to do three shows
four shows here and then uh yeah during
the pandemic you know maybe you know
when people go to Austin like I do yeah
Brenda has allowed me to be very lazy
Brendan will Brendan has this ability to
be consistently grinding like he can
take care of he'll be like it was you'd
start a podcast we have the studio now
he handles all the business oh well [__]
we are going to do that pillow talk for
a night because I have unlimited
capacity for work I gotta keep going
good non-stop I love it it really makes
me kind of I don't want to get stressed
I guess psoriasis now which maybe you
could tell me something about that I was
just so stressed immune disease it's
actually getting better do you have any
joint issues let me see your fingers no
zero that's what you got to watch out
for is if you start getting stuff in
there what do you mean stuff any
inflammation
arthritis no no no psoriasis are you
using just topical stuff are they giving
you something uh no I was looking at the
shot too yeah but my insurance ain't
covered because it's so expensive so
then I started doing the cream as
whatever I just changed my diet you know
what also inspired some people UV clears
it right up too exactly I ride my bike
with my shirt off in short shorts
no spots baby
hey Doc what do you think
that's hanging out all right what do you
got Jim
oh just a quick question why is it
inflammation in the the joints why is
that a thing though uh you know I don't
know the biology uh to answer that
accurately but generally the way these
things happen is they're just cross
reactivity so the immune system goes a
little haywire and starts attacking the
skin there's some antigen or something
on the surface of the cells there
they're seeing they look similar to
something on the joints and so they
start destroying the joints it's bad
it's active it's a nasty one you know
whenever you look if you look up
psoriatic arthritis hands just put a
picture up there syriotics or PSO sorry
attic look like the king of England's
hands and uh in the joints hands hands
and then just put a video a uh
uh oh geez we don't these are some yeah
God we used to see this so much there so
much good treatment that actually that
um that cartoon is actually more like
with no down down
cartoon yeah yeah that cartoon is
actually what we see all the time but we
have so many good treatments now that uh
yeah we don't see that so much yeah it's
bad no yeah I don't have that thank God
yeah I've been having like
random joint pain it doesn't go away
either pinky right there in the middle
yeah the pinky right here just that
joint that one and then like uh my
elbows yeah I don't know I mean you'd
first really what you would do is
make it be a million different things
right if you've got any diarrhea lately
that can cause that kind of stuff no and
and if you you would get just a basic
evaluation and make sure it's not gout
any gout in your family not their nose
because any it's called Olive articular
arthriting asymmetric single joint pain
that sometimes ends up being gout
something called pseudogout they can do
the same thing and then you know almost
anything in your system can cause joint
pains you want to get a general checkup
make sure book an appointment you didn't
do it on your own time
I stopped doing nightshades I lost my
all my stiffness in one week well but
that's like this he's having you know
specific joints it just has not gone
away that's the thing yeah you probably
just jammed it or something probably
just actually a mechanical thing but or
you're doing something you know you're
not wearing the bride affects your brain
too because he he scored the fight for
Henderson yeah so I was like oh you're
sick in the head speaking of fighting
I'm trying to get to the fight that you
always we watch the fights that video
You're possible the fight campaign yeah
I want to do that so badly but I don't
think I can make this next one so yeah
yeah we do a bunch all right
I love them yeah that'd be so fun we do
it with Rogan and Eddie Bravo and
corolla's coming to one too he told me
yeah Crow's gonna do one he knows that
much about MMA but he knows box he knows
box yeah but we we have people on there
don't know [__] about fighting it's just
a good time and I'll cover just another
game
when it comes to fight I can't by the
way you know I hope people don't take
offense to us we're not doing this you
know pejoratively you know what I'm
saying we're games
not to belittle anybody who actually is
yeah it's just we have features that I
suggest well my joke is if I see an
insanely muscular man like uh somebody
like we go to the on it things would you
be black football players Pro players
working out without a shirt on and do I
want to have sex with them no if I had
to rub them down in oil
what sport you're playing you have no
idea
oh that's when this black guy emailed me
we're talking about racism he goes hey
dude you're missing the point I'm a
doctor when I walk into a room I'm an
athletic looking guy I have to overcome
a whole bunch of assumptions you don't
have to and I was like ah fair enough I
used to they when I was early in my
career I was bigger and uh they used to
want to turn me into an orthopedic
surgeon because all the orthopedic
surgeons were big white guys who they
were and um and I'd like the cognitive
stuff much much more and so they people
had trouble with that a little bit
but it brings up a really interesting
topic as long as we're having these good
heady discussions today which is and I
bring this up with a Corolla and he
shoots me down every time but I I
totally jacked that was way back look at
the body damn those are some arms when I
was younger I was bigger still you know
I could lift a lot of weight man
um
so so back to you being a racist is that
is said I really believe that the the
term white supremacist has been Mis
allocated misused because
I've I've I'm not going to tell the
story I I was hearing people seeing
white supremacy everywhere and talk
about white supremacy I'm like I don't I
don't get I don't see it where are they
I've treated skinheads the only time
I've seen real white supremacist
skinheads are either in prison or in
recovery and they they're being healed
they go through it come out the other
side it's the only place I've ever seen
those guys and then I started think
about then I started reading some
biographies of Frederick Douglass in his
words like scales fell from my eyes he
called in one of his early speeches he
when that early speeches one of this in
this particular biography was an early
speech that I read
he was consecrating the uh it was
essentially the 13th Amendment the
monument in the Washington and he got up
he goes you guys don't want me to give a
speed it's like no no we really do go no
you don't no he gave it and he said uh
you really got a great guy did great
things white supremacist and I was like
oh are you like clutching my pearls
I get that he was a racist until he kind
of came around but he's always still you
think he's a white supremacist and then
I started really listening to these guys
and thinking a lot about it and really
what's being described is exactly what
we've just been talking about frankly
which is sort of this white Centric
eurocentric perspective like it's a
biased priori we prioritize our
naturally we're humans we do it's not
just that true it's also that we we were
a culture and a country founded by I get
it and it's a cultural or constraint
itself around that expression understood
and so I feel like it's our job to pay
attention it's all you got to do is pay
attention so all you say is when a black
guy comes on playing go hey rap for me
guys I want to say this I'm against
slavery so against racing inspiring how
to use the n-word much more things are
much better for him let's see what
happens I'm against it but I really do
think we all responsibility to it and
and I I've been saying this on Adam and
Drew podcast and people are pushing back
on me like oh no they're really talking
about real white supremacists I go no I
think they're taught they're just asking
us to pay attention and what's Adam and
we should do that he doesn't really get
what I'm saying so white supremacy like
as it's like eurocentrism or something
it's used academically is the idea that
so so they call Larry Elder a white
surprise yes what they mean is this and
I I disagree with this I've read Ibraham
Candy's terrible book Terrible book
called How to be anti-racist I've read
everything that has written read
Frederick douglasses he'll solve all our
problems Frederick Douglass now
Frederick Douglass also was born a slave
yeah and you know living in a very
different time and he's he's dead on but
I think that if you look at and I've
read a lot of the critical race
theorists I like to read it too and
there's some interesting scholarly stuff
in there but what what what what I think
that they the reason they they say you
know Larry Elder you're black you're uh
yeah white face because the idea would
be that as long as you profit from and
in uh the the American system and as
long as you are uh in any way advocating
anything other than the destruction of
the American institutions and systems
yeah you're a white supremacist I am
that's violently opposed to that that's
where it goes it is it is it is
insurrectionist yes and treasonous and
they're so dumb these academics are so
[__] dumb where's my camera their
their scholarship is anemic at best and
laughable
they've done no no reading they just
have opinions
she talks like that and I've read
Camille but but I and I read Camille
Paglia uh when 9 1991 but but um it's
it's you should listen to her talk now
she she attacks the post-structuralist
yeah absolutely it's it's the the
concepts like feminism like racism like
individualism were invented by the very
people that they are railing against
it's hilarious to me like do you know
who the biggest abolitionists were who
led the anti-slavery movement everyone
do you know who who spent more money on
anti-slavery initially and forcing
anti-slavery the British Navy the
British Navy the British Navy
spearheaded by what you and I would
consider the evangelicals now don't take
my word for it take the word of a black
scholar named Thomas Soul read a book
called White liberals and black rednecks
or black red white black rednecks and
white liberals it's a great book but you
know so so that that's the main thing to
keep in mind the African slave trade was
kept Alive by Africans and Arabs and
more slavery was going east than it was
going through foreign
ERS South Africa is super white [__]
dude I go a little crazy I'm not sure
with all this you're going to be able to
ingratiate the black men you like to
date yeah
no no I'm not I and don't fetishize
don't fetishize no I would never or
sexualize uh no I believe in human
potential and I think I believe in
equality of opportunity and uh equality
of opportunity and uh just Equity
amongst ourselves that we all treat each
other with absence I like the I like
what I like the idea so I said who was
it who said I'm a communist with my
family I'm a socialist with my town I'm
a Democrat with my city and I'm a
republican with the world or something
like that yeah that was you buddy give
us some current events Jen I shouldn't
have stayed so long I know you guys get
you guys do you think you guys you think
you got to cancel
what is going on in this video all right
I just need
you know when you said you were going on
crowd or I just I thought more you know
I thought you'd be doing like some real
good work okay so do we know any who the
players are here at all one's Brian
one's that's counting the the well first
of all that guy should have been hitting
me harder that's Darius who should have
been hitting me harder uh I can explain
I know I'm 56 in a cow suit now listen
there was an ad for good Rancher they
make great beef and it's a advertisement
whatever you're gonna say next doesn't
matter I know
Steven said uh at 56 did you think you'd
be doing this kind of acting because
well I don't believe in divorce so I'd
probably be home resolving and strength
who decided who was say that that's a
that's a no I know that's it whose call
was he you're supposed to be saying moo
um was that an acting choice or was that
a director he said we have a cow suit
and you're supposed to be a naughty cow
and I said to Steven say no more and
then I did that and maybe it was a
little out well you know what my kids
are going to see this and uh I should be
ashamed of myself yes you should it kind
of fell flat I apologize not very gay
it's not gay enough yeah it's really
nice okay I mean game as a gay man I'm
not I'd like a little more diversity too
yeah I know right animal activists and a
cow it could be he could be Italian
herbs he's wearing leather that's a
that's a hell of a beard
[Music]
um this one was in Australia some woman
apparently she was out for just a a
quick little trip by herself
didn't bring much supplies and then uh
she got stuck in the mud and she was
missing for five days her family's
worried about her so she survived off of
lollipops and a bottle of wine and she
doesn't drink that's my mom's diet
just kidding mom so if that had been two
weeks I would have been like say no way
but but five days no problem five days
yeah no water though but the main thing
is the main reason she survived is the
wine well you don't want to go near the
water because they're nothing but Crocs
yeah
Australia somewhere in Australia a
friend of mine got stuck in the in Cabo
after the hurricane remember the big
hurricane like eight years ago and uh
they they couldn't get out everything
shut down no water and they had to they
they filled their bathtub with water
before the hurricane drank that
immediately and from the rest of the the
I think they were down there for a week
margarita mix yeah alcohol from they
just stole it from all over the hotel
and just kept deal everyone survived
they were drunk the whole time but had
to keep drinking alcohol to stay
hydrated and you're sort of behind right
because it's all also a diuretic at the
same time so it's I think Everclear uh
well actually if you dilute it with
water it actually uh you can drink it
work as a yeah you can it'll hydrate you
but it also get you drunk I mean it's
like the strongest alcohol in your car
but there aren't those tablets you can
put in those iodine tablets that'll kill
off everything well you know do you know
I went to the I did the Special Forces
thing in the desert last year huh look
up uh Special Forces oh is that with
Rudy red yes or my boy it Rudy was great
that's my boy and you did like a day and
I will I was supposed to be longer than
a day
and uh yeah yeah that's me oh there's
the group oh dude that's great was it
really hard yeah
um
and it was 120 degrees and they kicked
our we drove out of helicopters
backwards did all kinds of stuff I think
that's me
um [__] dude and we did just you break
your neck no I I it it was real [__]
though it was real [__] in 120 geek heat
with you know 40 pound packs it was
brutal and you didn't see any producers
you just saw your staff and within three
days six of us were in the hospital what
oh wow yeah I was in the ICU next day
you were yeah heat stroke and
dehydration did some people make it
through it yeah look up that's me the
crazy picture of me on the gurney nope
down one well you're you're not look at
that that's me you're not trained for
that you're well I trained my ass off to
get ready
I know I look dead there yeah it's
ridiculous but I mean but that's that's
for young that's for like 30 year old 20
year olds let me see the picture of the
group chin and I like the diapers you
lasted one day it was a great group
we're all dude we're all great friends
now you lasted one day one day and uh a
couple of just scaramucci is that what's
his name is that that's scaramucci yeah
they're like celebrities
um yeah Mel B or whatever right Kate
Kate Gosling was in the high school
hospital bed next to me
the mom yeah K plus eight yeah case plus
eight uh what about we're out there with
Dwight Howard that's what Harwin yeah
Dwight how did he do he did really well
I got to the last four on that yeah he's
a great guy Piazza his age got him too
yeah after about a week he made about a
week he made it about a week yeah he did
well who lasted the whole way the
winners that were the two that made it
the end were a soccer player where's she
that's okay oh woman in this group here
the only women women made it to the end
the women the new the the headline of
this thing is women are [__] tough
how'd they do that and Hannah Brown in
the lower right hand corner there
uh Hannah Brown was The Bachelorette and
she made it all the way through where is
she let me see her how was it that she
did that down there was she doing the
same thing the guys were doing she was
doing everything she's young carrying
the same way too yeah well how about how
about uh Nadia Nastia Lucan nasty Luken
weighs 75 pounds and she had a 50 pound
pack on like she's an athlete she was a
gold medal gymnast okay but still like
ridiculous but that's a strong mind when
we got when we got in there and I saw
people like Nastia pick up that I was
like oh my God women are so tough now
did you guys shower at all there was a
shower but you couldn't you see Dwight
uh Dwight the comedy with Dwight was you
know our bathrooms were just these Woods
Woods I didn't see what he was packing
but but the thing I know this is the gay
show yeah but um we had these wood
stalls to [__] in and just [__] on a pan
essentially it was it was who are those
guys their Specialists that would be
Rudy's was a Recon Marine the two guys
on the ends are
um
uh British guys American guy is a great
guy named Remy adelukay he's got a great
story oh my God rough dudes yeah glad
you did it though Remy Remy was a
essentially a drug dealer trafficker
womanizer in the Bronx had had two
felonies out for him in New York and New
Jersey saw a movie about Special Forces
and decided I want to do that went to a
recruiting office the woman was like
what am I supposed to do the woman took
him into the courtroom and asked the
judges for a dispensation in two
different states wow got it and the
guy's now in Navy SEAL intelligence
officer and seal trainer damn still in
that great story Jesus that's awesome
it's a great story he's the greatest guy
so yeah man that stuff's no joke it's no
joke anyway it's not for a six-year-old
and uh yeah and I heard a lot of things
and I train I would the the physically
the running and all that which was
insane was not the problem I just wasn't
paying attention
running crawling eating out of water
just just beating ours it's cold was I
cold spent a lot of time being cold it
was 125 degrees I'm finally overheated
that's why I got heat stroke I'll take
hot this was but I the heat stroke once
it started it was like wow I didn't know
he gets that sick that fast
five liters of fluid before it could
stand up Jesus yeah so this is from the
Surgeon General saying that loneliness
poses the same risk as smoking God that
guy looks like I love that I don't
that's not true I love that he said that
because we have such a stigma on smoking
that I that he's going right at the
loneliness thing which is massive and by
the way thank you the federal government
and your public health officials for
putting people in Social isolation for
two years
so bad for you now they're like it is so
bad for you yeah I'm really angry about
this uh in young people ages 15 24
especially hard yeah no [__] it's really
really it's bad right Holiness increases
the risk of Premium premature death by
30 percent
it's so true though man yeah we've lost
it and by the way all meaning is derived
from other people everything I think
everything good in life is from other
people the veterans association the Elk
Lodge is all those things that people
had back used to have you ever read
bowling alone they're all gone there's
really no schooling alone it's about the
lack of the lack of clubs in the United
States you come anytime you can go meet
a group of people we've lost that as
Comics man he and I talk about it all
the time because it one of the great
things about going about going to with
the diaspora after covid where everybody
went to Texas but The Comedy Store hey
we would hang it was a hangnail we check
in come to Austin let's hang there yeah
I know there's a hang there there's
really no substitute for in-person
interaction yeah [__] that's what we're
talking about with the lockdowns man
is way up it's like Yeah because it was
down three years I'm so angry about this
I can't I can barely call it dude I'll
leave me here keep going Jim you're in
the same gay Circle I mean uh yeah
that's a guy Circle
uh Mark Zuckerberg so this is a little
weird apparently he won a silver and
gold medals in Jiu Jitsu but then I
guess there's a some sort of incident
that happened where he had to like
argue with the ref because he lost but
then apparently after you argue with the
ref the it was like a zero zero like
they was a ref went missing you know do
you know if he paid his opponents or not
I don't know but I mean hey he's winning
medals which is yeah
arguing with referee sort of the
opposite of the whole vibe of yeah
that's an interesting City might get
really good he's 38.
yeah you know
I'd say I wish I wish I traded that God
I can't with this boy
let me play this one for you hold on why
are you a family the 38 white
billionaire he did he get a high level
of jujitsu
h
are you looking for to work for Mark
Zuckerberg too what are you trying to do
here mate
have a backbone you know what I'm saying
give me some of that Mark Zuckerberg
would be good what else you got Jeff so
this is a TSA agent
um that you know sometimes you have dogs
to see you know sniff or whatever drugs
and it's not yeah so just look at what
he does to this dog and let me know what
you guys think so this is the owner the
master of the dog here
no that's that's the Kohler technique
yeah he's training so yeah so that's why
I want to get your opinion on this yeah
because they're [__] idiots the way
you it's it's called the color technique
so what you do is doesn't have a choke
on it that's how you train no so what
you do is you let the dog think that if
he doesn't watch you yeah he's gonna get
yanked yes that was that all all leash
training was done that way dog does the
dog does their own self-correction any
trainer can tell you that but they used
to do it with a choke chain yeah it used
to be that way you should but it's just
going back and forth yeah I'm more I'm
more worried about his uh cholesterol
story here that's a dog this guy dude
this guy see how he doesn't look at the
dog he just turns so the dog's got to
start he's not doing a good job though
no he looks like he's sick of the dog
[__] for sure yeah but he's just not
he's not doing but but what he's done
he's putting the dog in a distracting
environment too and he wants a drug to
continue to focus on him at all times
exactly and the dog is not doing it and
that's that's that's his job to train
the dog sometimes you gotta lay it down
on the dog show him who's boss but also
uh it's not just who's boss it's just I
could I could move in a certain way and
you better pay attention in case that's
what it is yeah whoever is that they
they suspended him so he's not he's not
fired he's suspended it's gonna be an
investigation because they're dumb
because that's called the color attack I
don't know but when you look at it just
says something you know as a dog owner
I'm sure you look at it like oh that
looks pretty bad but if you don't know
the details I was expecting a lot more
don't send your dog away for obedience
training then I've done that with my dog
that's right but this is also this is
also you know the cancel culture
probably hit up TSA and stuff like I
guess we ought to do something because
these people are so upset when they're
oh my God I mean someone films they're
just sport right imagine about the [__]
filming it don't you have a flight to
Canada she's just like yo here we go I
can't wait to get this is Kravitz Mrs
Kravitz remember me which Mrs Kravitz
looking through the curtains of the
neighbor yeah everybody's Mrs Kravitz is
so so true
um did you guys want to talk about that
shooting at all is it too much which one
the Texas one do they know what it was
about I mean obviously
apparently well they said he had some
sort of he said it was a white
supremacist
nationalists
there was another one somebody ran drove
a truck through somebody yeah and that
guy killed eight my kids they don't know
about him yet but he was also uh he was
uh they were all illegal he'd been
deported like one of the guys who killed
that whole family have been deported
eight times or something that's
different but the other guy was actually
also hold on you're illegal you're
getting confused so the Jen you're
regarding the Texas it was in Dallas
yeah and that guy did with the AR-15
killing eight people correct
and now what's interesting about him he
was in the military was kicked out of
the military for health
Wellness mental health issues so it's
crazy to me if a guy gets hit kicked out
of the military for mental health issues
even has a shot at locating a gun you
know I agree so there was like a some
sort of expert saying that it's not
about the mental illness because
DeSantis said that it's obviously about
uh mental illness which I agree mental
illness and then some professional guy
out some sort of like I don't know
Special Forces maybe special force or
something else said that no it's about
the gun the gun that killed her but it's
about the mental illness right it's both
obviously you have access to do it but
the reason why they're doing it is there
should be some restriction of access for
certain mental illness 100 and if we had
no guns in this country well of course
that would you wouldn't see this time he
would have used the machete right now
uh and but we that's not the world we
live in in this country and I don't know
how we've dialed that I hear a really
wild stat though yeah
so um
we are the at 193 countries I believe we
are number three in gun violence okay
but if you were to take the five cities
where there is the most gun violence
Chicago Philly I think Houston
um uh Chicago Philly Detroit uh L.A has
to be up to shoe numbers I I don't know
if it's LA but I think yeah all right so
it's all all these cities if you take
out the cities with the and they all
have these strictest gun controls so
it's St Louis
it's uh it's Detroit it's Chicago it's
Philadelphia and I think it's Los
Angeles and they have the strongest
they're very very tight gun laws if you
were to take all of those cities out
keep in mind they are blue I'm just
saying I'm not you know but if you were
to take them out of the equation we
would not be the third we would be the
189th that's pretty significant so a lot
of the gunfighters
a lot of it's gang on gang a lot of it
is uh is that so it's just I thought
yeah the gang gang is an issue but then
I'm not saying we don't have it with the
mass shootings that's literally a
problem as well because how many have
they had now look you know mass
shootings are a problem and we have to
do something about it I mean I I I I I
do think all of us know that no matter
where you are we're all looking over our
shoulder and I don't like that that's a
problem so and that happened pretty fast
too we got here quick yes got here quick
but it happened so much like that that's
barely even news now that's what's crazy
how do we Define what mental health is
then so because because you're a doctor
so if you've got because I'm all in
favor of keeping crazy people away from
guns I I really am the problem is then
you get when I talk to Second Amendment
guys they're all like how do you define
what mental health is that means
depression is yes
yes you're a professional do you get
cleared in order to get that right no
matter what it is there we have lost
track of of a use of say mental health
professionals judgment yeah it should be
okay and you should be okay to restrict
people from hurting themselves and other
people if it's your doctor's opinion
that you are of danger but what it
should be done we don't we don't allow
that at all now so what if your
ex-military ex-cop you whatever it is
you have you've been living a law
abiding life you have you own a bunch of
guns and now you are you suffering from
some PTSD or some depression and then
you get a psyche valve and that you hit
a red flag now does the state do you
want to have it come and get your guns
you see what I mean it gets very very
dicey have we had that happen though in
a mass shooter no
I'm just asking questions but what we
normally do is we have the family
collect the guns family or somebody else
take the guns away because there are
plenty of times when people are not
discharged from the hospital if they're
guns in the home plenty of times and you
go clear them out clear the guns out
yeah makes sense yeah because right now
even by the way Mindy McCready killed
herself because they [__] sent her
home with guns who is this
country was severely depressed her
fiancee just killed himself damn like we
got her set up got her hospitalized
talked her way out
they let her go with guns that was that
it's just there's so much you can't
imagine how horrible and how many people
we allow to die or kill other people who
could have easily been said yeah the
opiate thing I hope people got are still
getting that's Story number one yeah we
did that we created that and then we
perpetuated and then we killed people we
got to do something
you know when you get one mass shooting
after another and I feel like the
Republicans are saying more we need more
guns and after a while you're like hey
guys that I own guns but that doesn't
work well but on both sides like what
you're doing is clearly not working what
you're doing is clearly it's not a left
to right right it's solve a problem yeah
I don't care I agree whatever side
that's right very good point you know
we've lost track of pragmatism entirely
everything's ideological yes and we
should be just solving problems for
humans right pragmatically period right
yeah because now to do a background
check on uh to buy a automatic weapon
there's no history of your mental
nothing nothing gets alerted nothing
maybe everyone should have to get a
doctor's evaluation that's what I'm
saying well at least have some
background yeah hard to figure out
what's going on in somebody's brain I
don't think we're gonna figure out here
we have figured a lot of things out we
have figured out that we're all gay we
are okay we knew that coming in though
apparently I'm racist
[Laughter]
for years
that's an operation it's a lie yeah
yeah I'm in the ice house though I'm
doing sets all around La I'm at wow why
did you tell me I'm gonna put that on my
calendar right now yeah I live in
Pasadena come on in man May 19th job and
friends got some monsters on there one
show only I think it's at eight and then
uh I'll be in sets all of May around La
I'm at Laugh Factory on Friday so
shopping friends is May 19th and then La
Jolla comic store June 2nd through the
4th that's a Friday Saturday Sunday then
I'm off uh to Europe Belfast June 15th
Glasgow June 17th Manchester June 18th
London June 22nd card of June 23rd
ending the Europe Tour in Dublin June
25th tickets at thick toy.com
in Dublin I
mean archery this weekend uh actually
May 12th and 13th I'm not there May 11th
your website I know and then uh Helium
Comedy Club we got made uh Memorial Day
May 26 27 28 Friday Saturday Sunday
coming back on Monday Dr Drew shows
that's true.com uh Adam Drew show people
who won Loveline back we've been doing a
podcast together for 10 years everybody
all right I'm a Doctor Drew uh I have my
own podcast and then I have the
streaming show Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday three o'clock at Dr drew.tv and
then as we discussed uh drafter dark
over at your mom's house which is
another YouTube you're a busy man Dr
Drew we appreciate the time brother I
miss you guys we gotta do more of this
I'm coming May 19th I'm coming up let's
do it I'll probably ask Adam Adam was on
my last one so perfect we've done Dr
Drew thank you man appreciate it you
find the good fight see in the bathroom
I won't say anything that's going to
give me cancer